hi friends welcome back to Linux
networking command episode 4 so friends
till now we have covered almost 30 Linux
networking command and in today's
session also I am going to cover another
10 Linux networking command my friend so
let's start the session but if you are
new to this channel then please don't
forget to like share and subscribe the
channel and press the Bell icon for the
latest notification my friend please do
subscribe to this channel more and more
so that we can grow this channel
together my friend okay so let's start
with command
number 31 my friend so command number 31
is NC command and NC command stands for
nit cat command NC hyphen L and we are
going to capture the port here 8090 let
me show you how we can do this one my
friend so NC command basically why we
are using this one to arbitrary TCP and
UDP connection and listen let me show
show you how we can do this one my
friend so if you run the
NC hyphen L correct and then you need to
grab the port number 8090 correct so you
can see clearly it's telling an cat. to
8090 it's already in use and quitting
correct means you know we have already
installed Tomcat if you do psyph EF
right 5 and grip and just give Tom Cat
my friend correct so you know we have
already installed and we are using 8090
port for Tomcat this is why it's already
in use my
friend so friends let's move on to the
next command the next command is your SS
command and SS command stands for so
socket statistic okay so if you want to
see the socket statistic you can use the
uh SS command my friend hyphen t hyph a
uh you can use just type SS let me clear
this one first okay okay SS hyph t hyph
a okay Enter so you will be able to see
the socket statistic my friend here how
so it's going to show you which one is
listening what is you are receiving the
request okay how much you sending okay
what is the local address Port what is
the pr address port and what all
processes are there and if you want to
know more about like socket statistic
command you just do a man SS okay so you
will come to know what this socket
statistic command is basically do it's
another utility to investigate your
sockets my friend and what all options
iph a options to display like this one
right uh it's display both listening and
non- listening correct so this is how we
can use asss command my friend okay
let's clear this one and let's move on
to the next command my friend the next
command is NM CLI command friends please
pay attention to this command more and
more because in RS CSA exam 200 also you
need to use this command and this
command is very very useful my friend
this command is basically a command line
uh client for network manager my friend
okay so run this command NM CLI and then
connection so correct connection show
enter so you will be able to see the
interface name this uu ID is very very
important when you are troubleshooting
in the production environment this uu ID
is very very required and sometimes you
need to remove this uu ID my friend and
the new uh uu ID will be gets generated
okay so uh this is how we can use the NM
CLI connection show command to see the
to see the friend command line client
for network manager my friend okay so
friends let's move on to the next
command and the D command okay uh plus
short and uh then you can use a and
google.com so instead of google.com I'm
going to use my own
website that is Earth original.com you
already know okay and you know D command
we have already used before NS lookup
command we have already used before but
here we are going to use D command with
some set of options let's see what of
exactly the output we are going to get
over here basically this is also
performed for DNS lookup okay so let's
see okay so I am going to run the
command called Dick plus a earth
original uh.com my friend
and you can see directly so it is a
short uh way to get your IP so you know
already in the D command we are getting
uh the complete uh if you just do a dig
okay so you will come to know the
difference my friend okay what is the
difference so you are going to get the
complete detail if you are going to do
NS
lookup and just give you this one so you
are getting going to get the output like
this my friend it is a like it's IP to
host and host to IP is resolving or not
and in this one you are going to get all
your details like your C name and
everything all the details forward
lookup reverse lookup everything you are
going to get my friend over here
okay uh so yeah that's fine uh let's
clear this one uh so friends let's move
on to the next command the next command
is unload command and remember this
unload command you are not going to get
in your rhl 9 or in any of the drro so
you need to download this one uh the RPM
and then you need to install this one so
what is the use of unload command is
it's a visual representation of your
incoming and outgoing traffic my friend
let's see how it's showing okay so I'm
going to run a command called unload
command here you can see clearly it's
showing what is the incoming traffic I
am receiving for this IP means for this
machine and what is the outgoing traffic
here you you can see clearly what is the
current what is the average what is the
minimum what is the
maximum right so these are the details
you can see with the unload command but
please make sure you need to install
this unload you are not going to get
this one by default in your rhl 9 or any
of the flavor of Linux my friend okay so
you have to download the RPM and you
need to install you can see uh I have
already downloaded this one uh you can
see here and load command correct so
like this you need to download my friend
okay let's clear this one and let's move
on to the next command my friend I perf
command same again you can see here uh
if I do
LL uh I perf you can see I have already
downloaded this one so here also uh to
run the I perf command uh you need
obviously you need to download this one
and you need to install this this to
install this command my friend and why
we use this command this command is used
to tool for measuring TCP and UDP
bandwidth performance my friend okay
let's see how it works so I am going to
run the command called I per hyph C and
the server IP my friend what is the
server IP 192
16872 dot 214 my friend okay so this is
how we are going to get the here TCP
connect fi it's it's like that is
absolutely fine no worries okay but you
are going to get the output like this
okay so friends let's move on to the
next command this is very very important
command please pay attention and here
fping command you know there is
something called ping command to check
your host is reachable or not right you
are sending a icmp request to your host
so here also if you want to know the
multiple hosts are alive or not see hyph
G stands for alive okay how many hosts
are alive okay and you can uh put
multiple host you can put a range of
host also here you'll see how it works
exactly this is very very useful command
so please use this command in your
environment it's going to help you guys
okay so what I'm going to do is
uh app let's clear this one my friend
and uh first let me do a if config right
and F I'm going to run the command
called f ping and hyph G I'm going to
give this IP and before to this one I'm
going to give the other IP my friend one
one okay so you can clearly see it's
giving me these two IPS are alive rest
all IPS in between 211 to 214 that is 2
213 and 212 correct is
unreachable you get my point
understand so use this command this is
very very useful my friend okay you can
use multiple host at a
time okay so friends let's move on to
the next command the next command is
very very important that is if top
command and if top command same you need
to get this RPM downloaded and installed
in your Linux operating system whether
it's rhl 98 or any other drro also so
for this one this command basically
shows you realtime console based Network
bandwidth monitoring tool Network
bandwidth monitoring tool remember okay
so let me show you how it works my
friend let's REM uh clear this one if
top command correct and hyphen n c so
you are listening to which you can see
your IP is there and what it's giving
you console based Network bandwidth
monitoring tool this is very very useful
tool my friend you can get the all the
output like
this right this is interesting right so
please go through this command
carefully let's move on to the next
command my friend uh that is TCP dump
command hyph a hyphen I and your your
interface number and this is going to
capture and display the packets in asky
format let's see how it works my friend
okay so uh I first I'm going to run the
command called if have config to know
what is
my interface name and I'm let's clear
this one
TCP dump right hyph a hyph i and I'm
going to give my interface name you see
I'm going to get the output in aski
format you can see it's keep on running
my friend okay this is what this command
is capture and play packets in aski for
this is how I'm receiving the packet my
friend okay so friends uh okay friends
so now we came to the end of this
session so thank you for watching this
video for more videos like this just
stay tuned to my channel and please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
the channel and press the Bell icon for
the latest notification my friend till
then my friend just do take care of your
loved ones Jin and bye-bye